nicole buleshenko is 12 years old for
two months she's been sheltering from
the bombs in a city under attack
she is among hundreds of children
surviving underground in harkiv a metro
station now home school
playground and refuge
it is as safe as it gets here but nicole
wants to tell us it is no life at all
uh perez
i can't express how worried i am nicole
tells me it is so painful i'm anxious
about everyone i love
and of the people attacking her city she
says this
they are not human
then i ask about her mother and father
still at home with their three dogs
what about her family are her family
okay at the moment
yes she says
suddenly the things she wants to say
become too difficult but it is a glimpse
of the harrowing impact all this is
having on children here
this is the most important person in
these youngsters underground life
arena zolotoreva is a trauma
psychologist she sent her own children
out of the country because she wants to
be here to help those left behind those
who have seen and heard far too much
all of them went through some things she
says
some of them were caught in the shelling
or the bombing
some of them had no shelter because
their homes got hit
of course each of them has trauma
above ground their world is in ruins
this is what is left of an infant school
nearby
all wars turn children's lives upside
down
but this war is exacting a particularly
cruel cost on the classrooms of ukraine
if the school was a target it is a war
crime
if it was collateral damage it is at
best
dangerously reckless
this is what lessons look like now
in a cramped corner of the metro station
they are working hard here
but towards what kind of future
no one really knows
nicole gets comfort from one-on-one
sessions with arena it helps her
understand more about the catastrophe
engulfing her and despite the strain of
underground life she told me she will
not leave her cave
i've seen and heard everything but i am
not going anywhere i'm going to stay
here till the very end
it is not easy for anyone here
says i just want to comfort them and
make their trauma smaller and smaller
and smaller
these are bewildered and confused
children frightened by what is happening
to their world
a hug goes a long way here because
sometimes there are simply no words